[Music]  Diane Kruger and Norman Reedus pack on  the PDA the couple just couldn't keep  their hands off each other while being  snapped out in New York City Friday  night looking noticeably smitten the  pair sparked dating rumors back in  December when she attended the walking  dead stars photo exhibition in Paris  Kruger split from longtime boyfriend  Joshua Jackson after 10 years together  things have changed a little bit since  last time I was single  Joshua kept it pretty real about life  since his split when he stopped by Ellen  I mean everything's in your phone now  right swipe left if you want you're  somebody now anymore you talk to  somebody in there like oh no no we don't  do that anymore  so yeah that's it's been quite a big  change  you